Jay Sekulow serves as counsel to the
president and he joins us now from
Washington Jay good morning everybody
yesterday we learned that the Acting
Director of National Intelligence
considers this report to be serious it
was found to be credible and it's
believed that the whistleblower acted in
good faith so let's move to the to the
contents of the complaint and see if we
can agree on on some of the things that
have happened because as Republicans
pointed out hasn't been proven on the
question of whether the call was moved
to a server meant for intelligence
matters a political call moved to a
server meant for intelligence matters
and locked down there did that happen
and if so why well first of all not the
White House Council I'm the president's
counsel and that's a different role so
I'm not involved in what how the White
House internally handled has the
president eliches that he did that and
if so I will never tell you I first of
all I've never had that conversation the
president I'm not gonna tell you
conversations I had with the president
but let's get a couple of facts good
that you said initially here let's get
some things clarified this individual
has no first-hand knowledge none of the
events outlined in the document that to
to trump administration appointees have
found the report to be credible so what
my goal is here is to find out what is
what actually have let me answer the
question you asked and let me make sure
the questions that had information yes
but deemed hold it secondhand
information that would not be admissible
in a US district court in the Middle
District of Georgia okay get it handling
sir did what happen what if the
conversation moved into this separate
server and if so long you have the wrong
guest so not the White House Counsel I
am the president's counsel I don't
decide where things are moved or how
they're handled on a security security
matter then as the president's counsel
let's talk about the call that the
president Declassified and released a
partial transcript of a kind of call
summary well that was the trick hold it
there's the normal disclaimer on there
that was not a you know as you said a
word for word verbatim transcript that's
on these apparently that's the standard
operating practice the the question that
should be asked and and that's not being
asked here is
with the context of what took place at
the hearing yesterday
why didn't Adam ship just read the
transcript instead of doing a parody
when he started the event off as if it
was a Saturday night lion you Adam
Schiff and if you guys ever sit down
together regarding the call itself
according to the call summary the
president on July 25th a time when Joe
Biden was leading in the polls seem to
be a major rival of the president for
2020 the president brings up his name in
a conversation with a foreign leader
seeming to invite the uncovering of dirt
about a Maine a political rival was that
appropriate the there is no violation of
law rule regulation or statute with that
phone call as it approached look at the
president determines what communications
he wants to have and what he believes is
appropriate in his communications with
another head of state and by the way the
fact is the White House decided to
release this transcript and they gave it
to you all and they gave it to Congress
and abundance of transparency but we
should not be happy that conversations
with presidents are going to be
disclosed if this starts becoming a
regular practice as it will hold it it's
hard to conduct affairs of state with
other foreign leaders when this kind of
nonsense is going on the phrase this is
yes he did he did an abundance but I
don't think we should be gloating that
that's some great day for America that
we're releasing coldly trying to get on
the record what happened what did not
happen in the call the president brought
up Joe Biden and also invoked Rudy
Giuliani suggesting that his other
president and clearly be clear the
president of Ukraine raised Rudy
Giuliani so let's get that clear now go
ahead Rudy Giuliani was was said by the
president to be in touch with Ukraine to
talk about apparently digging up dirt
about a political rival has the
president ever asked you would you
accept that assignment if you were Rudy
Giuliani it has the president asking you
to do something solar all right first of
all I will have not been involved in
this but I will be very clear I'm not
going to discuss what the president
discussed with me about any event in the
context of attorney-client privilege
then number one number two I can go back
to the initial statement what
the conversation violates a rule
regulation or law what is the violation
of law that conversation mr. Sekulow
this is actually to Congress makes the
determination what the standard
analytical tap in a call involving
taxpayer money and the question of when
in a sense of Ukraine it was on hold for
multiple - involving president is the
President of the United States
the president is the president of United
States of course the call involves
taxpayer money what does that have to do
with rules regulations or statutes
nothing what song you're gonna hear the
call here's what you're doing he's
holding the funding at the time of the
call and he's asking you let me ask you
a question you have no to lose no
knowledge of the basis upon which
funding was held back or not you have no
now birthday and now can you enlighten
us sir I am NOT the what why are you
having so much trouble understanding
this you asked me to be a guest on your
broadcast you represent the president
isn't solves the friendships but I'm not
the White House Counsel I don't make
those decisions those are not
conversations I have so are you here to
talk about things other than your client
no I can talk about the transcript
that's what you invited me on your
broadcast to do and here's what we do
that and here's the question regarding
the transcript was it appropriate for
the president to invoke a for to invite
a foreign government to dig look at his
main political rival no let let's phrase
what he said did he say political I want
political Durham is that in the
transcript by the way don't use that in
the transcript political during on
arrival
he said he'd heard some very bad things
things that have knocking there's no
evidence I hope you'll get to the
transcript a friend said okay this is a
favor you say look into to corruption
let me ask you a question do you think
Ukraine's had an issue with you with
corruption of course and the President
believes that that's okay the Senate the
president to raise that issue the Senate
approved the aid back in hold on the
PERT the Senate approved the aid back in
May because they were satisfied that
significant steps have been taken to
root out that corruption it's yet to be
explained why the president held that
aid back for three months and then only
released it one day after Adam Schiff
requested the whistleblowers complaint
that's a
curious timeline if you can enlighten us
on it please do I'm gonna enlighten you
on something that you I don't think
you're you want to pay attention to and
that is the transcript itself you're
trying to figure out what was the basis
upon which the President of the United
States thought that there should be if
that is the case a whole back of funds
pending a whatever it was going to be
whatever issues the State Department and
all the other agencies were dealing with
I cannot look into that because I am the
private counsel so when you invite me on
your network let's be clear on what I
can and cannot say if we want to do this
again all right mr. Sekulow thank you
very much we appreciate your time